it's a world more peaceful since a
revolution it is a shame that your
people suffered but bounty hunting is a
complicated process
they said you were coming they said you
were the best in the Parcak would you
agree
[Music]
and then DeLorean
look outside
of waiting for you
yeah good
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have a new trailer for Star Wars the
Mandalorian that's premiering in a
couple weeks on Disney Plus so we'll
break it down there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs and I will be doing episode
videos for it so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
we'll do a Disney Plus giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
trailer on the video they change up the
beginning of the trailer a little bit
with that Werner Herzog voiceover as
he's walking past the helmets of the
storm troopers talking about the state
of the galaxy are things different now
are they better are they worse since the
rebellion there were some news outlets
reporting that the first episode would
begin with a big spoiler and I'm
assuming that it just has something to
do with the state of the galaxy because
most people have seen the Star Wars
films they understand that this is
supposed to take place after Return of
the Jedi by about five years the whole
idea is that things are in complete
chaos like he says are things more
peaceful no they are definitely not more
peaceful things are very gray it's
actually hard to make a living now
because everybody is scrambling for
power The Imperials that are left over
that didn't go to the Unknown Regions to
join the first order the rebellion
hasn't become the new republic yet and
even then when they did become the new
republic it sounds like based on what
happened during the new Star Wars films
that the entire galaxy didn't come along
for the ride you see the transed oceans
riding on those creatures they're not
due backs but they look similar to
dewbacks then they throw down he's using
the stun baton he is that giant blaster
rifle you get a much better look at
which is meant to be the blaster rifle
that Boba Fett used in the original Star
Wars Christmas special when he debuted
for the first time that was the first
appearance of the Boba Fett character so
they're going for some super deep cuts
Star Wars Easter eggs you noticed though
that he's actually wearing much more
worn down looking armor than he is later
in the trailer he puts them into
carbonite giving you a giant Empire
Strikes Back flashback to Boba Fett and
Han Solo in Cloud City the ship of his
is called the razor crest we got a shot
of it from the inside a little while ago
but it's just a repurposed freighter
that he's used after the Battle of Endor
there's a whole lot of cantina shots in
here this is just the place where a lot
of the bounty hunters congregate where
he meets with grief carga who's the
administrator or the leader of their
bounty hunters guild where he gets most
of his jobs from it's the same area that
we've been to before in the earlier
trailers just a lot of different shots
with a lot of other different characters
that we didn't see before
just because of the way the camera was
turned he talks about the mandalorian
being the best in the parsec parsec is a
unit of distance that's also meant to be
a joke about the Millennium Falcon line
from Han Solo in the original Star Wars
movie anewhopeee Chewie here tells me
you're looking for passage to the
Alderaan system yes indeed if it's a
fast ship fast ship you've never heard
of the Millennium Falcon should I have
it's a ship that made the Kessel run in
less than 12 parsecs we can make the
Kessel run in less than 12 parsecs
but parsecs are a unit of distance but
then it jumps to this shot here and you
notice that his armor is all shiny
looking like he's upgraded it with new
best car best car is the special medal
that Mandalorians used to upgrade the
armor it's an incredibly strong
incredibly rare incredibly expensive
metal alloy so it's a really big deal
that Werner Herzog's character is
offering that as payment for the bounty
that he hires him for which is a pretty
good clue that Werner Herzog's character
is kind of sinister that he's willing to
throw this around in the way that he's
talking to him things are complicated
but here's a ton of money to go pick up
this quarry that I'm looking for which
you see is this young child they finally
revealed the whole idea was is that it
was probably gonna be a little girl very
much in the tone of a spaghetti western
where you have this really evil
landowner type figure going after some
really innocent people you have the
gunslinger character like the Clint
Eastwood or now the mandalorian
character that's kind of caught in
between them and has to choose whether
or not to do the right thing or do the
thing that's gonna get him paid really
cool giant battle droids in the
background here there's a couple really
big action shots that we've seen so far
where the Mandalorian starts throwing
down with a bunch of other bounty
hunters so this might be after the other
bounty hunters come after him after he's
turned on his bounty in search to
protect a little kid this is just a much
longer version of that badass takedown
that we saw in the last trailer where he
pulls in through the circular door but
closes it while he's being pulled
through so it ends up chopping him in
half doing a little cattle rustling in
the mud then we see another one of his
bounty hunter companions who's another
one of the companions that he has
traveling with him just like IG 11
played by Taika Waititi the shot of him
riding across the horizon in the desert
and then standing across the horizon
line it just meant to be a very
spaghetti western type of shot where you
see the hero standing against the
horizon
this is a grave carga and a couple of
the other bounty hunters it's not really
clear what his relation
ship is gonna be with the Gina Carano
bounty hunter character her name is Cara
Doon she's just a former rebel shock
trooper who doesn't really know how to
adapt to civilian life so she'd become a
bounty hunter just like the rest of them
but there's been a bunch of shots of
them working together I don't know if
there's gonna be any kind of romance
between the two of them but they'll be
working together across the first season
and she is coming back for season two
they've already started filming season
two of this right now she posted this
early production picture to her
Instagram page you will remember Gus
fring from Breaking Bad he's playing an
imperial moth who's sort of scrambling
in the power vacuum left by the defeat
of the Empire and remember this is after
most of the Imperial remnants after the
Battle of Endor went to the battle of
jakku there was a big civil war between
the Imperials that were left over in the
survivors went off into the unknown
regions to create the first order so
he's one of the Imperial moths that was
in charge of this current sector where a
lot of the show takes place
who's scrambling to try and retain power
in the vacuum that's left that's why you
see a lot of these black deaths trooper
rogue one characters around him then
later in the trailer there's a really
badass shot of him flying the Imperial
TIE fighter with the Mandalorian trying
to use his grappling hook to hang on to
it midair the way he explains his
character is exactly the way that you
would expect him to the way he would
describe Gus fring like oh he's not an
evil person he has a sense of order he
wants things to work like a well-oiled
machine but the links that he goes to to
accomplish that are just really really
terrible so he comes off is more of a
villain more shots of IG 11 Tycho Brahe
TD said they're using the character for
a lot of the comedic relief because he's
doing all these WTF takedowns he's
amazing with weapons because he's
programmed that way but he has this
childlike innocence to him so he doesn't
really understand the context of what
he's doing all the time there's nobody
sense of morality to him it's unclear
who this character is but she might be
connected to the little kid that he's
trying to protect from Werner Herzog but
then you finally see Bill burrs new
bounty hunter character I knew that he
was in here but we hadn't seen any
footage of him yet love the way they in
the trailer with that bit of a throw
down line like Werner Herzog is telling
him they're waiting for you out there
yeah good one of the scenes that they
showed off at Star Wars Celebration
earlier this year that has not made it
online yet is him throwing down with
these stormtroopers in this room here
where he walks in and they had their
gunslinger standoff moment he's such a
badass that the stormtroopers basically
tell him it's four to one there's no way
you
when he says I like those odds is that
there's no way that they can beat him so
what's happening obviously is that these
episodes will air weekly it's mostly a
Friday show but when it premieres on
November 12th that'll be a Tuesday so
this is the actual full schedule of all
eight episodes you notice that once they
get to episodes 7 & 8 they changed the
date just a little bit because they
don't want to conflict with the release
of Star Wars Episode nine rise of
Skywalker I will be doing all the
episode videos so I'll just remind
people about the schedule changes when
we get to those episodes so no worries
they said that they have Easter eggs for
all kinds of Star Wars properties Dave
Filoni even teased that there would be
characters from the Clone Wars that they
would bring into the live-action shows
and even though you and McGregor's
obi-wan Kenobi is dead when this series
takes place he's already passed away and
he's become a force ghost the Disney
Plus Star Wars obi-wan series will start
shooting next summer there'll be six
episodes so it'll be more on par with
the Avengers Disney Plus shows that
Kevin Feige told us about because
they're already shooting Mandalorian
season two we'll see that before we see
the obi-wan series I'm assuming that
season two of this will premiere around
the same time next year just based on
their production schedule if you spotted
any big Easter eggs or anything huge in
the trailer that I didn't mention in the
video just write it below in the
comments but first episode coming
November 12th there might be some more
promos and footage that drop before then
while you wait for everything click here
for my Star Wars Episode nine trailer
video and click here to learn all about
the brand-new Superman TV show that's
coming next year thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight